when places like cambridge are hotter
than parts of the caribbean there really
is only one way to cool off
students tourists and hindus were among
those making the most of the sultry heat
the belief is the uk weather is really
bad but it's not really is it it's
beautiful
yeah it's very warm it's very nice
though
it's about somewhere
how much sun cream you got on
a whole bottle or do you need to take in
lots of water i mean what have you got
in your bag oh water like three bottles
of it how much water did you get through
on a day like this oh three liters four
really yeah
those who trade on the riverbank live
for this kind of weather
but precious commodities can be hard to
find
as can room on the water punting
companies predict their busiest weekend
of the year
we could to be doing
60 in in a day for our small company on
a very very busy day with the amount of
boats out there you could probably walk
across the river jumping across the
boats
it's not the hottest june day ever
though that record belongs to 1976 when
the thermometer reached 35.6 degrees in
southampton hairstyles and fashion
tastes aren't the only things that have
changed it was very localized to the uk
and the north western part of europe now
we're seeing seven different heatwaves
happening around the northern hemisphere
all at the same time a real indication
that climate change you know is leading
to more frequent heat waves that are
more prolonged and when they happen they
tend to be more intense
out on the river here you really get a
sense of just how strong the sun is
because there is of course very little
shade and for those people who can't
escape the heat it's this kind of
weather that presents real dangers
at this charity the homeless are given
sun cream and water as well as an indoor
space in which to shelter it's not just
winter when they need support
you're very
exposed to the elements no matter what
time of year when you're sleeping on the
streets but
our um community will tell us that it's
extremely hard to sleep at night um
you've got the complications in the
summer of um bites
mosquitoes and things like that but in
the very very hot weather there's
nowhere to shelter the road from whitney
comfort would be stopped
this week
honestly yeah we weren't for winter
cover we'll be stuffed
people use this center to
help themselves generously survive
when they come here to
you know receive help from the staff who
are very kind
the extreme weather's prompted a level
three heat health warning with people
advised to check in on vulnerable
friends and neighbours it won't last
long though hence why most are seizing
the chance for some sun
[Music]
ivor bennett sky news cambridge